Alhamdulillah.
Continuing
[Silence]
the chapter of
authored by Al of Muhamad
Abu Zak
and
we're at the narration of
Jundubada
[Silence]
that the messenger of Allah Sai wasallam
said three sentences.
These three sentences,
if a person were to truly embody them to
the best of his ability
and to truly embrace these three
sentences
and is able to move these three
commandments to the forefront of his
mind
to where every time he goes to say
anything,
do anything,
anytime He goes to make a decision.
These three sentences
are the basis of that decision. The
person cannot lose to a shaitan.
The person
will
by Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala's will be
victorious
and their scales will certainly
tend towards the side of goodness and
his good deeds will outweigh his bad.
He says
in the first of these three sentences,
"Obey Allah
wherever you are."
The second
and follow up any sin that you may
commit with a good deed
and it will erase it.
And deal with people with the best of
character.
these three sentences
because if we were to look at these
again from a bird's eye view,
we mentioned before many times and this
is how the Quran
begins with categorizing deeds
that deeds are of two types.
Worship in a general sense are two types
that all worship
is either worship that is specific
personal between you and Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala no other person is involved or
it is worship ship between you and
Allah, but someone else may be involved
or benefit from that worship.
And the the Quran begins with these two
types of worship. Those who establish
prayer
they establish prayer. Establishing
prayer is something specific to a person
as between him and Allah. No one else
benefits from that in a direct sense.
And from what we have given them, they
give to others. They spend for the sake
of Allah. This second
giving zak, giving, giving charity.
Anything that you have been given by
Allah, you use to benefit others with.
This here is
this is a
warship that involves other people.
Other people will benefit from this
worship. It is between me and Allah. But
others benefit and draw from the
benefits of this act of worship.
This narration
is exactly that exactly that formula
with respect to our worship of Allah.
Always obey Allah to the best of your
ability wherever you are.
However, sin is inevitable.
Every human being, every child of Adam
is a sinner.
It's not every child of Adam makes
mistakes. The narration says
every human being intentionally disobys
everyone. That's the narration.
Every son of Adam, every child of Adam
is a mis a sinner.
Yet the good amongst those sinners are
those who are in constant repentance.
foreign.
[Silence]
The prophet Sam
says every human being is a sinner. Not
just a sinner but one of continuous sin,
one of excessive sin. Then he says, "And
the good amongst them, not the best
because
It's the it doesn't translate to and the
best of sinners
are the ones who repent. No, because a
sinner who doesn't repent is not good.
There is no good in that sense in the
sense that we are speaking. Rather what
he is saying is and the good the
redeemed amongst those sinners are those
who are in constant repentance.
Constant repentance.
So this here paints for us a picture
very different than the picture of
oppression, the picture of
the picture of injustice that is
painted in modern Christianity. Modern
Christianity, Adam ate from the tree.
Actually, it wasn't Adam. It was all on
it was all on Eve. her and the sn the
snake ganged up on Adam. This is how
it's portrayed. And
you know he ate from the tree and so
now we have something that is an
innovation in the religions of the
prophets and messengers.
And what is that innovation?
The innovation of the idea of the
original sin.
Have we heard of the original sin
before? Has anybody here heard of this?
You've heard of this? Every one of us
has heard of this. What is the idea of
the original sin?
That no one is born with a clean slate.
As soon as you're born, you're guilty.
Before you're even of age,
before you are even able to
choose right from wrong, you're already
in the red.
That's original sin. That because the
forefathers sinned,
the children are all considered sinners
and have sinned without even sinning.
This is in exact
opposite of what Allah tells us. The
religions of MS and Isa and Ibraim and
said
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says
he says subhanahu wa'ta'ala
[Silence]
What is the religion of the messengers?
All of them their religion was always as
Allah said that no soul shall bear the
burden of another
and no person gets except that which he
has put forth for himself
and that you will meet and receive what
you have put forth for yourself on the
day of judgment and you will be
recompensed entirely for what you have
been what you have earned. This is the
religion. There is no original sin. Adam
sinned.
He repented from that sin and that is
erased. That's it.
Compare that to the very depressing.
Even though Adam repented, even though
repented,
that this vengeful God still punished.
Still punished. And not only that, but
would only forgive that sin if someone
totally innocent was murdered
in order to forgive that sin.
This is insanity.
This is the exact antithesis of
justice.
And so
we are not born with sin.
However,
we are born
as imperfect creatures that will sin.
And so the prophet sallallah.aii
wasallam tells us every human being
makes mistakes. Every human being is a
sinner.
However, the good the redeemed amongst
those sinners are those who are in
constant repentance. So here the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam tells us
observe Allah's obedience wherever you
are.
But even if you are very careful, even
if you try your hardest, you're still
going to fall weak.
Therefore,
when you fall weak, follow up a sin with
a good deed and it will erase it.
Remember we mentioned yesterday if for
every dollar I spent I saved a dollar
would I ever run out of money?
Impossible.
He says saiam
that is with respect to our worship that
is between us and Allah. But what about
what about the rights of others? He
says,
"And observe the best of character
with others." observe the best of
character with others. You know what's
really depressing?
What's really depressing
is the superficiality
of what modern society's idea of good
character is.
that good character is just big smiles
and fake hugs. This is not good
character. This is not what the prophet
sallallah.aii was speaking about
having a smile and gentle approach as
default. This is of good character but
it is not the epitome of good character.
Good character also involves justice.
Good character also involves honesty.
Good character also involves courage and
valor,
generosity.
Good character also involves jealousy.
Good character also invol involves
anger at the right places. Good
character also involve involves
harshness in the proper places.
All of this is part of what's good
character. When we look at the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam, Allah
praises him and praises his character
specifically.
Incredible
character.
Whenisha was asked about his character,
we all know it. What did she say?
that or
that his character was the Quran. What
do we find in the Quran?
We find
that the believers are described as
gentle with the believers, harsh on
their enemies.
Allah describes in the Quran Ysef
being patient in prison and not
reproaching.
But it also describes MS becoming so
angry for the sake of Allah that he
throws the tablets. Correct.
Is this not all part of good character?
Absolutely. What about if Moses came
back and found him worshiping the calf
and was like, "Guys, come on."
you know, you silly geese. You know,
this is this is not good. Let's let's
try to fix this, guys. Okay? I I don't
want to hurt your feelings and I don't
want to traumatize you all, but we
really shouldn't worship other than
Allah, you know? So, let's let's try to
avoid this, but I don't want to offend
you. Is that was that MS's approach?
Did he come back finding his people
worshiping the calf and say guys I I
don't prefer this but it's a difference
of opinion. So you know
is that is that was that his approach?
Absolutely not. when he was asked.
When he was asked,
when they passed by the people
worshiping those idols, and they said,
"Oh, MS, ask your Lord to designate for
us an idol they have idols." What
did he say? Well, we don't want to
separate people. We don't want to upset
anybody. We have to accommodate
everyone. So, you know, guys, over
time we'll start to learn about this,
but for now, let's just give them a
little bit of what they want so that
they don't leave Islam. Is this what
he said? No. Immediately, he said
this is ignorance.
Absolutely not.
And this is all part of what? Good
character. Now there is a difference
between that and harshness being the
default. Harshness being the default is
one of the
characteristics of the people of hell.
Harshness being a person's default is
one of the characteristics of the
dwellers of hell the damned.
Rather the default is gentleness. The
prophet sallall.aii alaihi wasallam
said, "Gentleness is not found in
anything but that it makes it better and
beautifies it." And harshness is not
found in anything except that it mars it
or is not t be gentleness is not
taken out of anything except that it
leaves it marred and ugly and distorted.
So the default is gentleness. The
default is the smile. The default is the
calmness. The default is the gathering.
However, that is not the only mode. And
if a person only has that mode and does
not become jealous for the sake of Allah
and angry for the sake of Allah and
gives for the sake of Allah and
withholds for the sake of Allah and
loves for the sake of Allah. If this
person does not have this they are
lacking an incredible amount of good
character
and
Allham.